ukraine then there will be no harvest
and that will have a long-term effect so
we've got to continue to focus on the
humanitarian impacts of the war while
looking for a ceasefire and an end to
and i said it very strong things by
that's been calling put in the worker no
i'm sure there's going to be harsh
exchanges in the meeting today too is do
you think that is is good is that going
to help is that going to make russia any
more cooperative
i think you're right there needs to be a
balance between
calling out russia's disinformation and
lies on this and that's a pretty harsh
thing to do
at the same time it is encouraging that
there's now been four rounds of talks we
haven't yet seen a ceasefire but there
seems to be at least progress and
willingness to continue those talks so
we want to continue to get that balance
right between
calling out the disinformation uh
holding russia to account while leaving
open the space to bring this awful
russian war to an end
thank you
let's speak loud because
i think we are moving in the right
direction
i hope we will be able to adopt it next
week
probably not at the beginning of next
week i think we are trying to reach
broad consensus
and uh
and i think there will be large support
for the resolution it will be a
resolution focused on humanitarian
issues humanitarian access
uh cessation of hostilities
access for humanity and agencies in
respect of international humanitarian
law the geneva conventions
before that tomorrow uh there will be a
vote on the russian draft in the
security council i think it will not be
adopted and to tell you the truth uh
this is very much the story of the
arsonists firefighter so you
launch a war you kill people you bomb
civilians and then you call for help so
i think this is the reason why this
this project is
not serious and i think it will fail
with a huge majority and this is why
mexico and france we will take this
initiative to the general assembly thank
you
oh
yes
david
foreign
uh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
8
900.
meeting of the security council is
called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is
threats to international peace and
security
i invite the
representative of poland and ukraine to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules i invite the
following briefers to participate in
this rosemary rosemary
under secretary general for political
and peace-building affairs
the world health organization
it is so decided
will now begin its consideration of item
two of the agenda
mr president
daily attacks continue to batter
ukrainian cities
many are reportedly indiscriminate
resulting in civilian casualties and
damage to civilian infrastructure
between 24 february and 15 march the
office of the high commissioner for
human rights recorded 1
900 civilian casualties
the total consists of 726 people killed
including 52 children and 1
174 injured including 63 children
the actual number is likely much higher
most of these casualties were caused by
the use and populated areas of explosive
weapons with a wide impact area
hundreds of residential buildings have
been damaged or destroyed as have
hospitals and schools
ohchr continues to monitor reports of
civilian casualties in the whole country
including in territory controlled by the
self-proclaimed donetsk and luhansk
people's republics
ohchr staff in donetsk are closely
following the developments regarding the
14 march incident in which 20 civilians
were reportedly killed by a tortuga u
missile that may have contained cluster
munitions
all such instances must be properly
investigated
it is the responsibility of all sides
to fully abide by their obligations to
protect the lives of all civilians
everywhere
ohchr is gravely concerned about reports
of arbitrary arrests and enforced
disappearances of civilians local
authorities and civil society activists
in russian-controlled areas
we call for their immediate release
mr president this week there were
positive signals
reported regarding the ongoing direct
talks between ukrainian and russian
representatives
we welcome all such engagements
however we note that these signals have
so far not translated into the secession
of hostilities that is so desperately
needed
the situation in the southeastern port
city of mariupol is particularly
alarming
many of the mariupl residents who have
not been able to safely evacuate lack
food water electricity and medical care
uncollected corpses lie on city streets
yesterday's strike on the marijuana
theater which reportedly served as a
bomb shelter for displaced civilians
adds to the list of attacks against
civilian structures
while early reports indicate that the
worst may have been avoided ongoing
fighting is hampering the rescue work
and assessment of the situation
mr president the devastation and
suffering in mario paul and harkeef
raises grave fears about the fate of
millions of residents of kiev in other
cities facing intensifying attacks
international humanitarian law is
crystal clear
civilians are entitled to protection
against the dangers arriving from
military operations
direct attacks on civilians are
prohibited
yet
the magnitude of civilian casualties and
the destruction of civilian
infrastructure in ukraine cannot be
denied
this demands a thorough investigation
and accountability
mr president the priority for the un and
its partners is to reach the people
trapped by the ongoing shelling
including in eastern ukraine
to that end we continue to scale up our
operations on the ground as
circumstances permit
the needs of the population are growing
by the day
the u.n calls for safe passage for
civilians from and humanitarian supplies
into encircled areas
we are grateful to neighboring
governments for their generosity in
receiving refugees and enabling the
provision of assistance to ukraine
the un is requesting all donors to
fast-track funding against pledges made
for the ukraine flash appeal
the appeal which seeks 1.1 billion
dollars to help 12 million people in
need is 36 percent funded
mr president undp projects that 90 of
the ukrainian population could be facing
poverty and extreme economic
vulnerability should the war continue
setting the country and the region back
decades and leaving deep social and
economic scars
as the secretary general highlighted
dangerous ripple effects of the conflict
are already being felt across the globe
russia and ukraine represent more than
half of the world's
supply of sunflower oil and 30 of the
world's wheat food fuel and fertilizer
prices are skyrocketing
supply chains are being disrupted
all of this is hitting the poorest the
hardest and potentially creating
instability around the globe
the secretary general announced on 14
march the establishment of a global
crisis response group on food energy and
finance to lead an effort with member
states to deal with the complex fallout
of the war
the deputy secretary general will lead
an interagency steering committee with
partners to oversee this effort
mr president the secretary general
welcomes all ongoing diplomatic contacts
he remains actively engaged with leaders
who are trying to bring about an end to
this war
there will be no winners to this
senseless conflict
the tremendous loss it is causing on the
other hand
is heartbreakingly clear
and it is going to get much much worse
the longer the fighting continues
the secretary general urges intensified
and coordinated political efforts for an
immediate secession of hostilities
there must be a meaningful sustained
political process to enable a peaceful
settlement
the lives of millions of ukrainians and
the peace and security of the entire
region and possibly beyond depend on it
thank you mr president
that's gonna say that the carlos i thank
mr carlo for her briefing
mr rauf
mr president it has been
less than
three weeks since high commissioner
gandhi addressed this council within
this short time span the number of
refugees from ukraine in the neighboring
countries has risen exponentially from
the then
520 000
to over 3.1 million today in what has
become the fastest growing refugee
crisis in europe since world war ii
with close to 2 million refugees from
ukraine
poland has in a matter of a few weeks
become one of the largest refugee
hosting countries in the world
some
490 000 people have fled to romania
350 000 to moldova
280 000 to hungary and 228
000 to slovakia
hundreds of thousands have now reached
other european countries
a sizable number of people have also
moved to the russian federation and to a
smaller extent to belarus
we are humbled by the remarkable
resilience of the refugees many of whom
have left their home with next to
nothing
and by the extraordinary hospitality of
the host authorities and host
communities
this solidarity illustrates the very
foundation of the international refugee
protection architecture and the spirit
of the global compact on refugees
the acts of compassion humanity and
kindness
we now witness daily bring hope and
brighten and otherwise very grim reality
we strongly commend the governments of
for receiving
of receiving countries for keeping their
borders open
to all those fleeing ukraine including
third country nationals who must
continue to be received without any
discrimination
the robust response that these countries
have mounted from scratch in an
extremely short period of time is truly
impressive
we are heartened by the bilateral and
other support extended to the principal
refugee hosting countries and the
funding committed to us so far in
support of the 1.1 billion
us dollar flash appeal for the response
inside ukraine and for the
550.6 million u.s dollars towards the
unhcr led regional refugee response plan
both
launched on the 1st of march
the outpouring of support from the
private sector and individuals who have
jointly provided some two-thirds of the
funds raised for the response so far
must be loaded
all international support to the
response is coordinated under the
refugee coordination model led by unhcr
which has been established in poland
moldova hungary romania and slovakia as
well as in other countries in the region
the sum of collective expertise and
support will be critical to help the
refugee population and support host
countries with shelter emergency relief
items cash assistance as well as mental
health and psycho
psychosocial support
indonesia has scaled up its response by
deploying over 200 experts and establish
field presence in all countries initial
staff on the ground and they take
regular protection monitoring at the
main border crossing points reception
centers and other locations where
refugee transit or gather
however
with the current pace of refugee
outflows the capacity of neighboring
countries are being tested and stretched
we can and must do more to support and
we must do it now
as the situation evolves unhcr in
coordination with the host government
and partners will assess the needs as
necessary and is currently adjusting the
regional refugee response lab
while some refugees transit through
countries neighboring ukraine many also
join families which have long settled in
these countries this is particularly the
case in poland where with time passing
and resources diminishing the number of
refugees needing integration will rise
they and the state which host them will
need support to ensure their inclusion
in all sectors of public life health and
education access to labor and other
services
with eu host countries receiving support
from the rest of the union we are
particularly concerned about the
situation in moldova where over
350 000 people have arrived
this refugee crisis comes on top of
pre-existing challenges
it is therefore crucial that sufficient
resources are made available quickly to
support the government's response
as critical as it is funding is only one
of the many forms of support that are
urgently needed we commend the recent
launch of the eu solidarity platform
designed to ease the pressure on the
country's neighboring ukraine through
transfers of vulnerable refugees to the
other eu member states we are grateful
to those member states that have already
made concrete pledges to transfer
refugees from moldova and encourage
others to join this initiative which
constitutes a remarkable and innovative
example of responsibility sharing in
line with the key tenets of the global
compact on refugees
in addition the eu activated for the
first time in its history the temporary
protection directive which enables
refugees asylum seekers and stateless
persons
to arriving in ukraine to quickly
regularize their legal status
alleviating pressure on asylum systems
it shall also enable refugees to find
work access services and benefit from
social protection
such temporary protection has also been
announced by the governments of the
united states canada switzerland brazil
and others
mr president i wish to further highlight
that 90 percent of the refugees fleeing
ukraine are women and children
indicating the heightened risk of
gender-based violence and other forms of
exploitation and abuse including
trafficking
as the secretary general said
for predators human traffickers
and human traffickers war is not a
tragedy it is an opportunity we are
deeply concerned about media reports of
incidents of gender-based violence and
trafficking and are supporting the
efforts of government in scaling up
prevention and risk mitigation measures
including through the stay safe campaign
aimed at awareness raising and provision
of information to refugees
as part of unhcr's leading role in
coordinating the un refugee response we
have also deployed experts in
psca coordinators to support the
government response in several refugee
hosting countries
mr president since the early days of
this crisis unhcr committed to stay and
deliver in ukraine and this is what we
have done allow me to take this
opportunity to express our deepest
gratitude and admiration for our
colleagues who have remained in ukraine
but also to the whole humanitarian
community
we believe that at least two million
people have been forced to flee within
ukraine close to 13 million people have
been affected in the hardest hit area
and the hardest and hardest hit by the
war in ukraine
many people remain trapped in areas of
escalating conflict and with essential
services disrupted are unable to meet
even the most basic of their needs in
many locations such as mario paul
residents face a critical and
potentially fatal shortage of food water
and medicines
people living with disability or serious
medical conditions
are particularly impacted unhcr is
closely tracking
negotiation for safe passage and is
preparing to send humanitarian supplies
as soon as conditions allow to
facilitate the provision of
life saving assistance to the population
most in need in ukraine we have adjusted
our operational presence relocating
offices and warehouses to the western
and central part of the country together
with partners we have been able to
deliver critical supplies for displaced
and conflict-affected populations
including core relief items and shelter
materials
we're working closely with local
authorities to establish and expand
reception capacity in main locations
where internally displaced people arrive
we coordinate the protection the
provision of key protection services
such as legal aid social accomplishments
psycho psychosocial support child
protection and gender-based violence
case management
where conditions allow we distribute
multi-purpose cash to help people make
choices best suited to their needs
flexible forms of assistance are crucial
as are innovative approaches
despite all efforts we are unable to
respond to the sheer scale of the
rapidly growing
needs of the ukrainian people and
systematically deliver the much
the much needed life-saving assistance
we cannot over emphasize the urgent call
repeatedly made by the secretary general
usg dicarlo erc griffith civilians and
civilian infrastructure must be
protected
international humanitarian law must be
upheld and safe passage for civilians in
any direction they choose must be
enabled
safe humanitarian access to those in
need
and unhindered delivery of aid including
through a functioning humanitarian
notification system remains of paramount
importance mr president
in conclusion allow me to paraphrase
high commissioner gandhi who is today in
tajikistan after having left afghanistan
yesterday on numerous occasions he
stressed that as we respond to the
crisis in ukraine we cannot abandon or
forget other recent and protracted
humanitarian crises in many regions of
africa latin america asia and the middle
east thank you
allah
mr president
excellencies
dear colleagues
good afternoon
and thank you for the opportunity
to address it today
the war in ukraine is having
a devastating consequence
for the health of ukraine's people
consequences
that will reverberate
for years
or decades to come
there is severe disruption to health
services
and access to basic commodities
as a result of widespread destruction of
infrastructure
including health facilities
who has verified 463 attacks on health
care
with 12 people killed
and 34 injured
including health workers
in any conflict
attacks on health care
are a violation of international
humanitarian law
they deprive people of urgently needed
care
and break already restrained health
systems
the disruption to services and supplies
in ukraine is causing an extreme risk to
people with cardiovascular disease
cancer
diabetes
hiv
and tb
which are among the leading cause of
mortality in ukraine
displacement poor shelter and
overcrowded living conditions caused by
the conflict are likely to increase
the risk of diseases such as measles
pneumonia
and polio
services for mental health and
psychosocial support
are urgently needed to help people cope
with the effects
of the war
there are
more than 35 000 mental health patients
in ukrainian psychiatric hospitals
and long-term care facilities
which are facing severe shortages of
medicines
food
heating
blankets
and
more the war is also exacerbating the
impact of the coveted 19 pandemic in
ukraine
with just one third of the adult
population fully vaccinated
this increases the risk of large numbers
of people developing
severe disease
critical shortages of oxygen will have
an impact on the ability to treat
patients with coffee 19 and many other
conditions
at least eight facilities
for producing and storing liquid oxygen
have now closed
and we're seeking ways of accessing
oxygen from neighboring countries
and ways to deliver it
safely to where it's needed
doublehc is on the ground
working with the ministry of health and
partners to support health workers
and the health system
to provide care
to meet immediate health needs
so far
we have sent about 100 metric tons of
medical supplies including oxygen
insulin surgical supplies
anesthetics and blood transfusion kits
enough for
4500 trauma patients and 450 thousand
primary health care patients for one
month
other equipment including oxygen
generators
electrical generators
and defibrillators
have also been delivered and we're
preparing to send the further 108 metric
tons
we have now established supply lines
from our warehouse in live to many
cities of ukraine
but challenges with access remain
we need unfettered access
we have critical supplies ready
for you and joint convoys to enter
difficult areas but so far
we have not been successful
today for example the un convoy to sumi
that included a double-edged truck
carrying critical medical supplies was
unable to enter
loads ready for maripo
remain in staging areas and cannot
proceed
access to this
and other areas
is now critical
to support ukraine cell system
who is coordinating the deployment of 20
emergency medical teams
consisting of experts from many
countries
to deliver care across a range of
disciplines
in ukraine and neighboring countries
which have been generous in welcoming
refugees but are struggling to meet
their needs as my colleagues earlier
said
those needs are immense
and include continuity of care for basic
illnesses
as well as more complex issues like
cancer and renal dialysis maternal and
child health hiv and tb sexual and
reproductive health and mental health
refugees and many of those who remain in
ukraine are already very vulnerable
especially
women
and girls
protecting them from abuse and
exploitation of all kinds
must be a top priority for hosting
governments
and for all international organizations
mr president
today i have three urgent requests
first
we urge the security council to work for
an immediate ceasefire
and a political solution
prolonged conflict is in nobody's
interest
and will only prolong the suffering of
the most vulnerable
the life-saving medicine we need right
now is
peace
second
we urge all donors to support the
response to humanitarian needs
in ukraine and neighbouring countries
which are immense and escalating every
day
thanks to donors
who front loaded which is contingency
fund for emergencies
we were able to respond immediately
deploying
these funds were supplemented
by additional funding
from the un
central emergency response fund surf
however
to sustain the response we call on
donors to fully fund the united nations
emergency appeal
as the under secretary general said it's
only 36 percent so far funded
we thank those donors who have already
pledged funding to meet the needs of
people in ukraine
and third
although ukraine is rightly the focus of
the world's attention
i urge you
not to lose sight of the many other
crises in which people are suffering
in afghanistan
more than half the population is in need
with widespread malnutrition and a surge
in measles among many other challenges
in ethiopia
the blockade of 6 million people in t
drive for almost 500 days has created a
catastrophic food and health crisis
in the syrian arab republic
more than 12 million people are in need
of health assistance almost half of them
children
and in yemen
roughly two thirds of the population
more than 20 million people are
estimated to be in need of health
assistance
mr president
in every case
the only solution
is peace
i repeat
in every case
the only solution is peace
and our world needs peace more than ever
as if kovid is not enough
to have a devastating war like this
is
dangerous for the world
i
to make
thank you mr president and thank you to
the briefers for your briefing today
just three weeks ago
russia launched its unprovoked
unjustified
unconscionable full-scale invasion into
ukraine
and assault on democracy
now over 3 million refugees have fled
the country
creating a devastating humanitarian
crisis felt around the
world these refugees are mostly women
and children
they stuffed their lives into backpacks
and left their homes and everything they
knew behind
today
many of them know that their apartment
buildings and streets
have been bombed to rubble
and the horrors continue
for those who remain in ukraine
we just heard from the w whodg
that 43 hospitals have been attacked by
russia
43 hospitals and health facilities
ap reporters on the ground showed the
world a mass grave in mariopool
a narrow trench
filled with the bodies of children
yesterday russian forces dropped a
powerful bomb that hit a maripool
theater
where hundreds of civilians were hiding
the russian word for children
was written outside the theater both
front and back in large white letters
that could have been seen from the sky
yet russian forces bombed it anyway
local officials have told families to
leave their dead relatives lying outside
on the streets
exposed to the world because it is
simply too dangerous with the bombs and
shellings to hold funerals
i just met with ukrainian civil society
leaders
they reported that people standing in a
breadline trying to get food to feed
their families were shot dead by russian
soldiers
they reported terror
the terror that russia is inflicting
across ukraine on the ukrainian people
russia will be held accountable for its
atrocities
there's only one way
one way to end this madness
president putin
stop the killing
withdraw your forces
leave ukraine once and for all
yesterday i listened to presidents
president zielinski's speech to the
united states congress and i was so
moved by his words his bravery and his
calls for help
and for peace
immediately afterward president biden
announced another 800 million dollars in
security assistance to help ukraine
defend itself
that's more than one billion dollars in
the past week alone
we're not doing this by ourselves our
allies and partners are fully committed
to surging assistance to the ukrainians
and we're grateful to all of our allies
and partners who have opened their
borders and their hearts and welcome
ukrainian refugees
we're also going to continue to provide
humanitarian relief to support people
within ukraine and those who have been
forced to flee including the 186 million
dollars in additional assets assistance
that secretary blinken announced on
tuesday
here at the united nations we believe
the best way to address the humanitarian
crisis is through a resolution
in the un general assembly
the resolution in the general assembly
will reflect the views of the
overwhelming majority of u.n member
states
and ukraine itself
the international court of justice
issued a profound and important order
yesterday to the russian federation
and we call on russia to comply
immediately
russia has clearly violated
international law
by violating the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine
russia's brutal tactics have killed
civilians medics and some of the
journalists who have been showing us all
the truth of this war
russia has attacked so much of what we
hold sacred
and everything
everything
the united nations stands for
russia's actions must be condemned in no
uncertain terms
as president biden said
ukraine will never be a victory for
putin
no matter what advances he makes
no matter whom he kills or what cities
he destroys
ukraine will never be a victory
for him
the united states stands with ukraine
and the ukrainian people
and we will do everything
everything in our power to end this
tragic
unnecessary war
thank you
i thank the representative of the united
states for her statement and give the
floor to the representative
thank you mr president
thank you rosemary for your clarity and
the very valuable information you
provide every time you come to brief the
council
thank you mr mazzu and director general
yabrezus for your sobering information
dear colleagues three weeks into this
unprovoked unjustified illegal and
deadly aggression by russia and the
terrible facts are hardly surprising
since anticipated nearly to the detail
massive casualties
among civilians
mass graves
widespread destruction of civilian
infrastructure
ruined homes schools and hospitals
lives blown away by bombardments
children dreams shared into smoke
there is no need to describe this
devastating situation
yet as we just heard and by the top u.n
representatives not by the so-called
west hysteria
is soul-wrenching and coincides with the
shocking media reports on the horrors of
the war
that and the misery unleashed upon
ukraine for no reason
i will maybe just recall the summarizing
words of the secretary general when he
said two days ago
ukraine is in fire and is being
decimated
guess by who
over three million
three million refugees in only three
weeks
more than the entire population of my
country
some two million people displaced
internally
12 million people affected in the area's
hardest hit by the war
unicef has evidence that since the start
of the war forced by this brutal
aggression
every second a child has crossed the
border of ukraine
srsg patton warns that abuse
risks of sexual and gender-based
violence as well as
trafficking
continue to mount amid wide-scale
displacement
several appeals for humanitarian
corridors to evacuate civilians went
unheeded
many people remain trapped in areas and
conflict
and with essential services disrupted
are unable to meet their basic needs
including food water and medicine
for the estimated hundreds of thousands
who remain
there is simply nowhere to go they can
be killed even for queueing for bread as
it happened
this is the angry and the true face of
the russian aggression
mr president
the director of who that we just heard
confirmed that there have been 33
attacks on ukrainian healthcare
facilities
infrastructure and workers since the
beginning of the invasion otherwise two
every day
there are unfortunately nearly a dozen
conflicts in the world today
out of 89 attacks on health system
around the world this year so far
33 have been only in ukraine
therefore attacking healthcare
facilities and workers is becoming a
tactic of war in ukraine
nothing is being spared
first there was this maternity ward in
maripora
then there was a mosque
yesterday russians bombed the drama
theater in mariopol
a shelter for nearly a thousand citizens
who were not able to flee the city
and as it was mentioned the world
children in large russian script was
painted on the ground outside the
theater
everything must be bumped
despite this grueling picture
the main news is not just what i said
the main news is that ukraine is holding
on
that ukraine is resisting
that ukraine is winning and russia is
deep in the mud
on the ground
morally legally and internationally
and we know now that for russia to win
this war
of choice
it has to grozny the entire ukraine
it has to aleppo all its cities
it has to manipulate
everything there
and even after that we will be told here
again
that it's not their fault
it's
mr president
ukraine won yesterday the first legal
victory of the international court of
justice
icj the guardian of international law
ruled that there was no evidence to
support russian claims that ukraine was
committing genocide in the luhansk and
the nets
the court called for immediate
suspension of any kind of military
operations by russia and entities
organizations or persons under its
control
so the question is
will russia respect the court's order
or will it unplug and cancel itself
completely entirely from the
international law
mr president beyond the human toll the
infrastructure and residential
deliberate destructions in large-scale
humanitarian crisis
there is another major crisis the
economic impact of the aggression
undp has warned that every day of
delayed peace will accelerate a free
fall into poverty in ukraine
undp again
projected yesterday
that ninety percent of the ukrainian
population could be facing poverty and
extreme economic vulnerability should
the war deepen
in the event of a continuing protracted
war in ukraine
almost one third of the population will
fall be below the poverty line and a
further 62
will be at ris extreme risk of falling
into poverty within the next 12 months
it warned again the undp
that 18 years of social economic
achievement could be lost
and this would set the country and
entire region back decades
leaving deep social and economic scars
for generations to come
who in this room or outside it believes
than a single word from russia about
sdgs about agenda 2030
because these terrible effects will not
only be felt in ukraine but in the
entire world
mr president
russia has proposed a text for a
humanitarian resolution we think it is
wrong
it is worse it's a mockery of
proportions
a move worth of the guinness record of
hypocrisy
russia cannot shoot first and then come
disguised as a doctor
the only way to minimize humanitarian
consequences for the ukrainian
population
is simple
russia has to stop the war withdraw its
troops and go home
no one should get confused by a text
just because it is called humanitarian
when the only aim is to provide cover
for the war
so colleagues
don't fall for the new clothes of the
emperor
the russian aggression is naked out
there
thank you
albany representative of albania and
give the floor to the representative of
the uk
thank you mr president and i join others
in thanking our briefers today as well
as we've heard
it's three weeks since we met in this
chamber
to make one final effort to avert a
russian invasion of ukraine
it's three weeks
since we were interrupted by the news
that president putin had abandoned
diplomacy and chosen war
these have been three
devastatingly long weeks
for the people of ukraine
for the three million people who have
fled
and for those who have stayed
as we heard from the u n
russian forces are laying siege
to populated cities and towns
an indiscriminately
shelling residential areas with high
impact weaponry
including cluster munitions
43 healthcare facilities
including a maternity hospital
have been attacked
killing the most vulnerable
and depriving civilians of access to
medical assistance
and presidents putin's war
is causing suffering
well beyond ukraine's borders
thousands of students many from nations
around this table have been caught up in
the violence
the war is spiking food and energy
prices
bringing further pain
to countries in the developing world
already suffering from the impact of
covid and famine and conflict and
climate
millions of refugees have been taken in
by countries across europe
mr president
colleagues
three weeks since the start of russia's
invasion
one point should be clear in our minds
this is an unprovoked war of aggression
waged by russia
russia is responsible for the suffering
it has inflicted on ukraine and beyond
russia alone
can end this war
141 u.n member states
have unequivocally condemned russia's
illegal invasion
the international court of justice
has issued a legally binding order
requiring russia to suspend military
action in ukraine immediately
this week
perversely
russia tabled a resolution
that among other things
called for the protection of civilians
including women and children
this
is cynical game playing
in the face of human suffering
just yesterday
in mario poll
russian forces reportedly targeted
civilians
taking cover from the onslaught
despite the word children
written on the ground where they
sheltered
if russia really wanted to protect women
and children
it would withdraw its troops from
ukraine
and end this illegal invasion today
thank you mr president
have you represented
the uk foreign
is
yeah
against hospitals
rise to the level of war crimes
the targeting of journalists
obligation of armed forces
is
[Music]
hello
if
of
the international community is united in
its massive combination of russia
many countries including france have
immediately taken measures
targeting russian authorities issuing
economic circles close to the ocean
powers
cut off access to their resources
these sanctions
effectively
representative
thank you president i also would like to
thank under secretary general
de carlo
assistant high commissioner mazu and
director general dr teddrus for their
very sobering briefings
their messages are grim very grim
we commend all humanitarian
organizations working to alleviate the
man-made catastrophe being visited on
ukraine
president the cause of this catastrophe
is clear
three short weeks ago as we sat in this
very chamber as the secretary general
pleaded for peace
the russian federation invaded ukraine
since then
we have witnessed wanton devastation in
a sovereign independent nation
with no regard for human life
to date over three million people have
had to flee ukraine becoming refugees in
neighboring countries
we heard today 90 of those forced out of
their homes and into
uncertainty
are women and children
families torn apart
at least two million people are
internally displaced
increasingly vulnerable and in need of
immediate support
ordinary people traumatized by a cruel
and reckless war
women and girls face heightened risk of
being subjected to sexual and
gender-based violence
including rape and trafficking
their right to protection is being
ignored
the destruction of the basic services
all of us here at this table take for
granted food water sanitary systems
health and education is having a
devastating effect in ukraine
civilian casualties we know are in the
thousands
irish journalist pierre sachewski
was tragically killed alongside
ukrainian journalist sasha kushnova
they were both working to shine a light
on ukraine crane's plight
our thoughts are with their families
and every grieving and suffering
ukrainian family
courageous journalists are showing the
horrific impact of russian aggression
i salute the free media putting their
lives on the line to show us the truth
the humanitarian impact of this war is
being felt around the world
it will affect the food security of
countries heavily reliant on ukrainian
agricultural products including in
africa asia and the middle east
it will cause severe harm far beyond the
borders of ukraine
president i find it a damning indictment
that this council has to plead with the
russian federation
not to deprive civilian populations of
food and water
not to deny them the basic
infrastructure they need for daily
existence
for survival
it's a damning indictment
that we in this council have not been
able to speak with the united voice to
save innocent lives in this war
president the images from a besieged
mario pool are shocking
we see once again
that urban warfare takes the heaviest
toll on civilians
we deplored the targeting of health care
facilities doctors taken hostage
life-saving care interfered with by
military forces
last week's attack by russian forces on
a maternity hospital in mariopol
plumbed new depths
resulting in the death of a mother and
her newborn baby a baby that never had a
chance
we have to ask how many more
the residents of mariopol have are now
melting snow or siphoning water from
heating systems to quench their thirst
they're cutting down trees for firewood
for cooking
and to stay warm in freezing night
temperatures
the city's supermarkets emptied because
the basic necessities of life cannot be
safely brought
into the city
it is chilling to think that the
suffering forced unmarriable
may be visited on other ukrainian cities
there can be no justification for this
brutal aggression
it should never have been perpetrated it
must be stopped
ireland calls on the russian federation
to comply with its obligations to
protect civilian health care facilities
and medical and humanitarian personnel
it must facilitate the safe passage and
unhindered delivery of humanitarian
assistance including medical and food
supplies
whatever is agreed or not agreed on
humanitarian corridors or other measures
civilians and civilian infrastructure
must be protected under international
humanitarian law
this applies both to those who choose to
leave
and those who choose to remain
surely
the most basic respect for human life
must mean something to the aggressor
even now
let's be clear the provision of
humanitarian assistance is not dependent
on a ceasefire
it is dependent on those bombing cities
doing the right thing in accordance with
their obligations
president attacks directed against civil
civilians and civilian objects
indiscriminate attacks and
disproportionate attacks
are all prohibited under international
humanitarian law
ireland remains gravely concerned by the
humanitarian harm arising from use of
explosive weapons in populated areas in
ukraine
there have been reports of the use of
cluster munitions and thermal baric
weapons by russian military forces
these weapons cause mass casualties
they pose great risk for civilians when
deployed in urban areas including long
after fighting has ceased
their use is unconscionable
equally
any use of white phosphorus against
civilians or civilian infrastructure is
apparent and contrary to international
law
president not only is russia's war in
ukraine morally wrong
it is illegal
yesterday in granting ukraine's request
for provisional measures against the
russian federation the international
court of justice was clear
it was emphatic
russia must immediately suspend the
military operations in ukraine
in light of the court's decision which
is binding on the russian federation
which it cannot ignore
ireland once again calls on the russian
federation to comply with its
obligations under international law and
immediately end its aggression
unconditionally withdraw its forces from
the entire territory of ukraine
and refrain from further threat or use
of force of any kind against ukraine or
any other member state
president colleagues for three long
weeks
diplomacy has proved unavailing
for three long weeks the world has
watched this war with horror
yet
we believe there is still a chance for
peace
we urge the russian federation to do the
right thing
and commit to the diplomatic path in
good faith
it is never too late to do the right
thing
thank
[Music]
thank you president
i join others in thanking briefers for
their sobering presentations
three weeks ago russia launched its
military aggression and invaded ukraine
and since the start of the war
a ukrainian child has become a refugee
almost every second
over 3 million civilians have crossed
the borders into neighboring countries
seeking protection
and over 2 million people are displaced
inside ukraine
they are fleeing from the horrors of
russia's unjust and illegal war against
ukraine
from the destructive power of one of the
world's biggest war machines
from russia's shelling of homes schools
and hospitals
from russia's indiscriminate use of
explosive weapons
and their deplorable use of cluster
bombs
weapons that destroy cities
killing civilians even while they are
fleeing or hiding
the human suffering is unacceptable
we encourage countries to keep their
borders open to all those seeking safety
outside ukraine without
discrimination
and we commend the generosity of the
neighboring countries and their
solidarity with those fleeing the war
many of those fleeing are in a
vulnerable situation as we heard from dr
teldrass
at risk of sexual and gender-based
violence trafficking and other forms of
exploitation
traumatized children and adults in need
of mental and psychosocial support
we encourage the humanitarian
organization to give priority to these
issues in their response
president
civilian must be protected at all times
and humanitarian and medical worker must
also be protected and allowed safe rapid
and unhindered access to people in need
the protection of civilians and
humanitarian access are not a matter of
choice
they are legal obligation under
international humanitarian law
obligation which must be respected
and those responsible for violation must
be held accountable
president russia's war is causing
despair and suffering with global
implication
russia is responsible for the increased
food prices and higher risk of food
insecurity that many countries now face
russia's war against ukraine will
further exacerbate humanitarian crises
death and disaster for people across
continents
russia and russia alone bears the sole
responsibility for the war and
humanitarian crisis
russia must stop its military aggression
against ukraine
russia must comply with the order by the
international court of justice to
immediately suspend its military
operation in ukraine
if russia cares about the humanitarian
suffering this war is causing
then russia should stop its senseless
and illegal war
the russian draft resolution has no
credibility it will not stop the war and
the suffering
we echo the call of the secretary
general
that political dialogue negotiation and
mediation are the only way forward
we need to see genuine talks that
translate into concrete results on the
ground
and they must be inclusive
we need to see women included
meaningfully in all talks negotiation
and mediation efforts
and for the sake of humanity
this war must stop
thank you
from norway and india has a floor
thank you mr president
let me thank usj de carlo
unhcr assistant high commissioner
mazou
and who director general dr
gabrezas for their respective briefing
on the security and humanitarian
situation in ukraine
india continues to remain deeply
concerned at the ongoing situation
which has progressively deteriorated
since the beginning of the hostilities
the conflict has resulted
in death of civilians displacement of
thousands of people internally
an outflow of more than 3 million
refugees to neighboring countries
the humanitarian situation has worsened
particularly in the conflict zones
there is an urgent need therefore to
address the humanitarian needs of the
affected population
in this regard we support the
initiatives of the un and its agencies
who have mobilized whatever is possible
in the shortest possible time frame
we hope the international community will
continue to respond positively
to the humanitarian needs of the people
of ukraine including through extending
generous support to secretary general's
flash appeal and the regional refugee
response plan on ukraine
keeping in view the dire humanitarian
situation unfolding in ukraine india has
already sent over 90 tons of
humanitarian supplies to ukraine and its
neighbors as a part of the nine separate
tranche of humanitarian assistance
delivered thus far
these supplies have included medicines
and other essential relief material
we are in the process of identifying
other such requirements and sending
further supplies in the coming days
india has ensured the safe return of
about 22 500 indians from ukraine
we have also assisted nationals from 18
other countries in that process
we are deeply appreciative of the
facilitation rendered by the authorities
of ukraine and its neighboring countries
in ensuring their safe return
allow me to underscore that it is
important that the humanitarian action
is always guided by the principles of
humanitarian assistance which is
humanity neutrality impartiality and
independence
these measures should not be politicized
we reiterate our call for immediate
secession of hostilities across ukraine
our prime minister has reiterated this
on several occasions and called for
immediate ceasefire and emphasized that
there is no option but the path of
dialogue and diplomacy
we stand ready to continue to engage on
these objectives in the security council
as well as with the parties in the
coming days
we continue to underline the need to
respect the u.n charter international
law and the sovereignty and the
territorial integrity of states i thank
you mr president
and i now give the floor to the
representative of ghana
mr
president i thank you for convening this
meeting and also thank the distinguished
briefers for the updated information on
the prevailing humanitarian situation in
ukraine
i also welcome the participation in this
meeting of the representatives of poland
and ukraine
mr president
ghana reiterates once more the call on
the russian federation for an
unconditional and immediate ceasefire
and for the withdrawal of all its
invading troops from the internationally
recognized borders of ukraine
the cessation of hostilities is critical
to save lives and prevent further
devastation to the ukrainian people
it remains fundamental to addressing the
worsening humanitarian situation
we remain deeply concerned about the
military escalations and the
disproportionate use of unconventional
munitions in bombarding the cities and
civilian populated areas of ukraine
and we are disheartened by the trauma
that the situation has caused especially
to the aged women and children
the parties to the conflict must
urgently commit to a humanitarian pause
to enable the evacuation and safe
passage of civilians and facilitate the
delivery of food medicine and other
essential services to those in critical
need and those who have been caught up
in the cities under siege
we also deplore the attacks on medical
facilities and call for the protection
of humanitarian workers and medical
personnel
we urge the parties to comply with their
commitments under international law and
international humanitarian law in
particular the provisions of the fourth
geneva convention of 1949 relating to
the protection of civilian persons in
the time of war
we continue to urge the parties to
accept the path of diplomacy and
dialogue in resolving their security
concerns
we believe that the good officers of the
secretary general should be leveraged to
facilitate a peaceful resolution of the
conflict
mr president in concluding i wish to
emphasize that the interest and safety
of the ukrainian people should be
prioritized and must be at the forefront
of the actions of this council and all
other international actions i thank you
for your kind attention
i thank the representative and i now
give the floor
to
is
all causes for concern
and humanitarian personnel as well
mr president
i thank the briefers for their
presentations this afternoon
kenya is gravely concerned that three
weeks on
the armed conflict in ukraine has
continued unabated
the continuing reports of loss of lives
and displacement and separation of loved
ones including through millions of
refugees in just three weeks
is deeply disturbing
kenya extends
its condolences to the families who have
lost loved ones to the conflicts and
stance in solidarity
with all the affected
we commend ukraine's neighbors
for opening their borders to refugees of
multiple nationalities
and we urge them to continue ensuring
that protections sought are offered with
no discrimination on any basis and
particularly in regard to race or
religion
kenya condemns the targeting on and
destruction of civilian objects
and infrastructure
particularly residential homes hospitals
and shelters
the parties are obliged to comply with
international humanitarian law
we remind that civilians including
foreign nationals in ukraine are not
party to the conflict and must not be a
target
in this regard
all actors including the parties must
consider to prioritize the safety and
interests of civilians in accordance
with international humanitarian law
the imperative to ensure that
humanitarian passages are open and
functioning in all times cannot be
overstated
we believe that there is
an urgent need for humanitarian
resolution that reflects the unity
and the resolve of this council to
assist the people of ukraine
ultimately
the only way out of this crisis is an
immediate and unconditional cessation of
the military campaign
we urge the parties to do this to allow
humanitarian assistance to flow and
create room for diplomacy and
constructive dialogue including through
the good offices of the u.n secretary
general towards a sustainable political
solution
we underscore the need for an urgent
resolution of this armed conflict
its impact is already being felt through
increased food prices fertilizer oil and
other essentials
by multiple countries
if it is not quickly prevented this
trend including
the added effects of unilateral
sanctions will aggravate
state fragilities
and fuel ongoing conflicts across the
world especially in the global south
in closing mr president
kenya
restates its recognition of the
sovereignty
the editorial integrity
and the political independence of
ukraine
and i now give the floor to the
representative of brazil thank you
mr president
at the outset i would like to thank for
their briefings miss jos marie de carlo
the wto director general tetrus
gabrezus and mr rauf mazu from
unhcr
as the conflict in ukraine lingers on
the dire humanitarian situation in the
region is further deteriorating
brazil is deeply concerned with the
growing number of civilian casualties
including children
as well as the increasing flows of
refugees and internally displaced people
according to some estimates
the number of
people impacted by the conflict is
around 18 million
of which more than 6 million are
internally displaced and nearly 3
million people have flattened ukraine
the destruction of infrastructure
has caused food shortages energy outages
and intermittent communications
under these circumstances
supply chains have been disrupted
the access to medical facilities is
impaired
medical supplies are running low
their distribution is uncertain and some
stockpiles are out of reach due to
military operation operations
hospitals and medical personnel are
struggling to provide care to the sick
and wounded
in response to the most pressing needs
for humanitarian assistance
the brazilian government has sent last
week a donation encompassing water
purifiers around nine tons of foods
and half a ton of medical items
totaling approximately twenty thousand
twenty thousand items donated by the
brazilian ministry of health
with the assistance of the embassy of
brazil universal
the supplies were landed at that capital
and delivered to ukraine in coordination
with the country's authorities
the international community must come to
the assistance of the people most in
need
not only those directly afflicted by the
hostilities in ukraine territory
but also refugees in the neighboring
countries
we commend
the world health organization for its
work to ensure the delivery of health
supplies to ukraine and its neighboring
countries
the availability of medical personnel
medicines and health equipment is
crucial to meet the urgent needs of
those sick and wounded
at this moment ukraine's health system
is under critical pressure to cope with
the demands for assistance from the many
victims of this conflict
it is distressing
to know that as of 12 march
the world health organization
had verified 31 attacks
on health care facilities in ukraine
resulting in dozens of deaths and
injuries including
health workers
the attacks against health care
are
particularly worrisome since they
deprive people of life-saving services
attacks on health care are violations of
international humanitarian law
we reiterate our position that the
immediate cessation of hostilities in
ukraine is the main condition to
guarantee the passage of civilians from
confrontated zones to safe areas
moreover
only with a comprehensive and effective
ceasefire it would be allowed the rapid
safe and unhindered access to
humanitarian assistance to those in need
i thank you mr president
which is unfolding in a number of
regions in ukraine
council are also rightfully pointing to
it
the difference here is that that will be
assessments of some
particular western states
in addition
ukraine is reaching new and new heights
and it started at the very beginning at
the
military
uh
three hospitals
it is
um medical facilities in ukraine it's
something that we have many questions
about and we'll revert to that
this has been refuted many time ago
there are no russian
this is the consequences of just
distributing weapons to whoever wants to
have them
during this
two other
5 000 pieces of automatic weapons had
been distributed to population at large
now the mosque
sultan suleiman mosque in mario
residents
during one single meeting of security
council that will be a guinness book
record
the fabric manufacturing fakes
and the western
and around this city well let me explain
to you why this this place is special
in the course of events in 2014 2015.
when the ukrainians
those who lived in the east of the
country uh it threw um planes and tanks
against them
at the time
of resistance in the donetsk
the citizens almost unanimously
supported the independence of the
republic during the referendum and they
were actively speaking about speaking
out against the nationalism
and the ukrainian nazis cannot forget
that cannot forgive
you they drowned the city
and they made it
headquarters and the mainstay of the
voluntary nazi battalions first and
foremost
battalion and the right sector one
airport
jail which is also a torture center with
all of the attributes
with bodies of people solitary
confinement chainsaws this is not even
the uh middle ages this is near nazism
even the poet and that is precisely why
the ukrainian radicals are clinging to
this
second of all they understand that they
will have to be held accountable for it
when you go play at the moment and
that's why they're
ready to drag into the and and to to to
to drag into
the grave almost entire uh population of
marijuana
exactly the way it was run by the nazis
in berlin in 1945 when it was besieged
they also hold people as human beings
they do not allow them to evacuate and
they place right next to residential
buildings heavy weaponry in violation of
international humanitarian law
yet
this is something that our westerners
and
secretariat representatives is something
they do not
want to see
but it's very difficult to cover up
facts and he would like to point you to
the icrc statement which sheds lights
light on these facts
and in such a situation it's not a
surprise that mario paul has been
almost a leader
on the number and ingeniousness of the
united states
dwell on the three most egregious of
them and the first one of course
is
the former maternity hospital
allegedly destroyed by the russians i'm
not going to dwell on this too long
it is very difficult
experts who say nothing
hit the building but rather there was an
explosion there
after all the second fake something that
we heard about today also
russia allegedly hit the marijuana
theater where more than 5 000 people had
sought refuge
already on the 13th of march
there was a widely available public
information provided by by private
people
who managed miraculously to escape the
you can see the word children
the uh russian armed forces were
informed about the situation
and the building of the theater was
never considered as a target for a
striker
such places of provocation you can very
frequently find western reporters who
briskly report on that this is something
that's become a tragic hallmark of
provocations in ukraine who are covering
up the excesses conducted by national
nationalist battalions and ukrainian
armed forces
make sure that
against the center of donetsk well
buddha
and this is presented as something that
had taken place in kiev
after that um it's very difficult for us
to ask you to be uh rational in your
assessment once again
anything about the tragedy in donetsk
which resulted in 20 deaths
and the third fake now
allegedly is
forcing the people from
other ukrainians
russia therefore only humanitarian
corridors into ukraine should be opened
this is a bare facelift
since the beginning of a special
operation the hotline of the ministry of
defense of russia received more than 2.5
million requests
for being evacuated into russia
unfortunately we have to state that we
have not been able to evacuate everyone
yet but this is because the ukrainian
authorities are prohibiting
but during the previous 24 hours alone
they finally opened up long suffering
we managed to ensure the evacuation of
more than 31 000 civilians including 89
nationals
among
71 osce staff
nine greek nationals and nine pakistani
nationals
and her son oblast under the control of
the russian
armed forces and categorically refused
to move over to their territories and a
key of control
the whole humanitarian operation
operation was conducted by the dnr
forces and russian armed forces without
any participation
i'd like you to draw your attention to
the facts
of people moving towards banjanska and
belitopul freed from ukrainian
nazis is 10 kilometers long
uh russian liberators and
the city this is not something that was
seen and this is not a surprise because
the peaceful civilians were needed for
by the nazis as a human shield
and those who escaped from marijuana are
telling us about mass atrocities and
crimes conducted by the territorial
defense but the abuses against the
elderly women and children and all of
these people and being individually
provided with medical and psychological
assistance
the situation in other areas is varies
objective control including with the use
of drones
and those who managed to break through
were being
shot at
yesterday the hardcore direction once
again there was a column of buses full
of refugees they were moving along the
humanitarian corridor towards russia
as a result four people died and they're
injured
[Music]
out of them 2 242 children it was
natural
overall since the beginning of a special
military operation already two hundred
and seventy one
thousand people out of them 58 000
children have been um
evacuated
they have crossed the uh border of
russia
and this includes a
31 000 individual cars
and we stand ready to take
[Music]
which remains in many places the only
possible
means of survival
ukrainian cities resell to local
entrepreneurs
these facts have been reliably
established
um
[Music]
ukraine because there's a very high
danger of mines and this was created by
cuban authorities
and territorials
and this also is related to the possible
provocations of by the ukrainian armed
forces
we continue
sending humanitarian assistance to the
needy in ukraine
alone received more than 450 tons of
food medicines and basic
the second necessities march our
emergency services and the ministry of
the
defense supply to
various regions of ukraine including
donbass supplied about 3 000 tons of
humanitarian cargo including
construction materials another issue
here
of cases the local administrations are
threatening punishment to those who
receive
humanitarian assistance
basically every day we
see um
information from western capitals that
they are providing kiev with yet another
um cargo of all kinds of weaponry
yesterday washington announced that this
week ukraine will receive from then
defense assistance to the amount of one
billion dollars
you are fueling uh this conflict pouring
orders into it it is already clear now
what kind of
tragedy resulted from simply
distributing light's weapons to anyone
who wanted them without any control i
wonder
whether the western taxpayers know about
the risks of this weaponry ending
everyone
it was not noticed even though it
crossed over several countries from the
western point in in ukraine to zagreb
that's 700 more than 700 kilometers
for mr president
we know that
the brain
is
including um women children then the
elderly um
would not be now dealing with a
salacious uproar
surrounding the
it stopped being humanitarian
immediately and became full of
political formulas which have nothing to
do with humanitarian issues
we were clearly told the western
countries didn't need this for projects
without them
in order to end up with an anti-product
so they are ready to push it forward not
in the security council but in the
general assembly ignoring the fact that
such this kind of document will help
humanitarians nothing but what i see
russia
would put forward its own draft
containing within it everything that the
libertarians need
it does not contain political
assessments
and this is not the kind of assessment
that you can find in other humanitarian
resolutions either and we open this
document for the co-sponsorship by all
you and members
of the humanitarian resolution submitted
by russia
is not something that satisfies western
countries
and this shows the true goal sponsor
one of the sponsors of the first
so-called humanitarian
pressure uh by western partners that
their arms are being twisted including
blackmail and blackmailing threats
albania has disseminated a letter
difficult it is for those countries to
withstand this kind of onslaught
in the course of the special military
operations
and right
now we are going to forward the letter
on that to the emirati presidency i
thank you
is deeply worried
about the worsening humanitarian
situation in ukraine and depose the
reported increase in civilian casualties
and refugees
the pressing task now is to call for
maximum restraint from all parties and
to ensure safety and security of all
civilians including women and children
and meeting their basic humanitarian
needs
so as to prevent the occurrence of a
larger scale humanitarian crisis
china supports the work by the relevant
parties in maintaining communication
ensuring safe and an impeded
humanitarian corridor and further
facilitating personnel evacuation and
humanitarian assistance
the number of refugees and displaced
persons caused by the conflict is still
on
huge impact on ukraine and the
surrounding countries
china
and who among others
effectively conducting operations and
mobilizing the international community
to assist
all those in need
in the recent past
some people of african or middle east
descent
encountered difficulties during
evacuations
this should be taken seriously and
addressed properly
all refugees regardless of color race or
religion
shall be
accorded the necessary protection and
the international refugee law
china pays high attention to the
humanitarian situation in ukraine and
has put forward a six-point proposal
the red cross society of china has
provided ukraine with three batches of
humanitarian supplies
with the third one containing
milk powder and quilts for children
specifically helping the red cross
society of ukraine assist displaced
children affected by the conflict
we welcome
any initiative or proposal from any
party that contributes to alleviating
and resolving the humanitarian crisis in
ukraine
the security council has a primary
responsibility for maintaining
international peace and security and
should therefore play a positive role in
easing the humanitarian situation in
ukraine china hopes
that the council can stay united on the
humanitarian issue
and demonstrate a constructive attitude
mr president
the international community shares the
common aspirations for cease fire at an
early date to elevate the situation on
the ground and to prevent civilian
casualties this is also the aspiration
of china
to date
russia and ukraine have held four rounds
of negotiations
keeping the negotiations going means
there is a chance for ceasefire
and that there is a chance for a
peaceful future
china remains committed to promoting
peace through negotiations we support
the u.n and the parties concerned in
vigorously carrying out good offices
we also hope
that all parties will do more to
facilitate peace talks
not to
add fuel to fire
that wanting use of sanctions will not
solve any problem but will instead
create new problems
given the sluggish recovery in global
economy
ever-escalating sanctions
are undermining stability in
international industrial chain and
supply chain
thus exacerbating food and energy crises
damaging people's likelihood in all
countries developing countries in
particular
and triggering new humanitarian
consequences this is also an issue that
the security council shall pay attention
to when addressing the humanitarian
situation in ukraine thank you mr
president
[Music]
thank you very much
is
is
i wish to
the largest numbers
the needs of those who do not have
access to business services
and medicine
and medical
organization has recorded 43 attacks on
medical institutions in ukraine and the
fact that
honestly
attacking
installations
medical things
as well
security
foreign
ordering
the fundamental premise for humanitarian
assistance
the cessation of hostilities
mr president
is
[Music]
in which we have been engaged
thank you very much
foreign
at the same time
civilians
my country appreciates the questions
by receiving refugees
our experiences
continued
disregarded
a solution to the crisis can only be
achieved
inter and international security and
stability
i now reserve my functions as president
of the council
on the floor to give an additional
intervention you have the floor
thank you very much i was momentarily
pleased to hear that the russians were
pulling down the vote on their fascicle
humanitarian resolution which was doomed
to fail
we know if russia really truly cared
about humanitarian uh crises the one
that it created it could simply stop its
attacks on the people of ukraine
but instead they want to call for
another security council meeting to use
this council as a venue for its
disinformation and for promoting its
propaganda
let us not forget that russia is the
aggressor here they are the ones that
are creating a pretext for attacks on
their own people
and we can't be fooled by by their
efforts here
they have troops inside of ukraine they
are killing people inside of ukraine
that is the reason for us being here
today not to deal with their propaganda
thank you
for the representative of the united
states
mr president
distinguished members of the security
council
madame under secretary
general dicarlo
director general assistant high
commissioner
i also recognize the representative of
the aggressor state present here in the
permanent state of the soviet union
let me begin with a quote
the operation is developing successfully
and in strict accordance with plans
that have been previously
approved
end of quote
said by putin yesterday
three weeks after the unprovoked and
unjustified russian invasion of ukraine
started
over these weeks the international
community was wrestled
with the question
why
why has the russian federation decided
to cosplay the nazi third reich by
attacking the peaceful neighboring state
and plunging the region into war
what are the reasons and what is the
plan
and yesterday we got the answer
killing ukrainian children
108 innocent souls so far
let me quote again
success
in the strict accordance
with the plans
approved
previously
according to putin
children are deliberate target
given yesterday's bombardment of the
mario paul drama theater
a shelter for hundreds of local
residents mostly women and children
despite the big signs
children painted on the road on both
sides of the building
being clearly visible
russian pilots dropped an aerial bomb
the building was fully damaged but the
shelter fortunately withstood
it did not turn into one of more mass
as putin's plan probably
envisaged
previously approved
of course putin's plan does not limit
murders to children only
all civilian ukrainians and foreign
citizens are under threat
the office of the high commissioner for
human rights recorded 726 confirmed
cases of killing of civilians
while believing that the real figures
are considerably higher
and they are indeed
just yesterday in the city of chernihev
53 civilian residents were killed by
russian bombs and shells
on the same day
in marefa
haki region
21 people were killed following russian
shelling
that destroyed the local school and
residential buildings
the plan is also to raise ukrainian
cities to the ground kharkiv sumi
walnawaha akhtirka izum
in mariupol
payne for ukraine and the entire world
and an eternal shame for russia
almost
2400
confirmed victims among the civilian
population
ninety percent of the city's
infrastructure has been destroyed
russian troops seized one of the
hospitals
gathered 400 civilians there and used
the building as a military position
hiding behind civilians as a human
shield
let me quote
the sufferings of marijuana must not
become the future of ukraine end of
quote
said by peter mower the icrc president
who is currently in ukraine
the plan of putin is to violate the
agreements on ceasefire and safe passage
for the civilian population from the
temporarily occupied territories
yesterday russian troops shelled a
convoy of civilian vehicles headed from
mariupol to zaparilla
five people were killed
many injured including children
and the plan is previously approved
to terrorize local residents who remain
in the territories seized by russian
troops
small villages where the russian
soldiers stay suffer the most
russians break into houses
throw people out into the streets
take their food
eyewitness reports of tortures
abductions of local officials and even
extrajudicial killings come from across
the occupied territories
enforcing ukrainians to flee their homes
as refugees has also been a part of this
barbarossa style plan
almost 3.2 million refugees have left
ukraine so far
against the backdrop of the increasingly
aggravated humanitarian situation russia
has dared to table a draft humanitarian
resolution of the security council
an appeal by a serial killer
to the end members to co-sponsor this
most egregious hypocrisy is outrageous
they may like to think twice
if they want before they rather before
they dive into the blood of children and
adults executed by the russian military
in ukraine
and let me quote saint patrick in this
regard
never trust a dog to watch your food
at the same time there is no doubt
that action on the humanitarian front in
the u.n is urgently required and i
encourage all responsible nations to
support the relevant efforts in the
general assembly
i also encourage all to join the group
of friends of accountability following
the aggression against ukraine
co-founded by albania colombia
denmark the marshall island islands the
netherlands and ukraine
this group will act as a forum among um
member states for the discussion and
promotion of accountability measures in
ukraine following the russian military
aggression
distinguished members of the security
council
yesterday the international court of
justice delivered its order on
provisional measures in the case
concerning allegations of genocide under
the convention on prevention and
punishment of the crime of genocide
ukraine versus russian federation
the court ordered that the russian
federation shall immediately suspend the
military operations that it commenced on
the 24th february 2022
in the territory of ukraine
despite the order being binding on
russia under the iran charter
today the kremlin has openly and
bludently disregarded it
stating that they and i quote cannot
take this order into account end of
quote because there is no i quote
agreement between the sites
and the quote
and should it be surprising for us
i don't think so
as from the very first instance of
russia's presence in the u.n it was in
content of the u.n charter
that was the case when russia was
allowed to occupy the soviet seat in the
u.n and the security council
that was the case in georgia
in syria
as well as in ukraine's crimea and on
bus in 2014
i encourage the security council members
to exercise their duties
envisaged by the article
94.2 of the u.n charter to make
recommendations or decide upon measures
to be taken in the case of russia's
failure to comply with the obligations
incumbent upon it under the judgment
rendered by the court
mr president
perpetration induced
traumatic stress although known as pits
is a form of post-traumatic stress
disorder
its symptoms are caused by being an
active participant in causing trauma
sufferers of pits
may be found in many roles
such as soldiers
or executioners
where they are expected to cause trauma
including death
but diplomats
especially here in the united nations
especially here in the security council
compared to the more well-known and
understood ptsd
there are there appears to be greater
severity and different symptom patterns
for those affected by pits
the case of the military aggression of
russia against ukraine and the mass
atrocities perpetrated by the russian
army
ordered by putin
and defended by the russian diplomats
will be examined by scholars and
scientists
including in the areas of sociology
history
philosophy
psychiatry and theology
today however i would like to quote
from into the abyss
a documentary about executioners
of the death penalty
one guard began crying and shaking
uncontrollably
when i quote
the eyes of all the inmates
he had executed
began flashing before him
end of quote
ambassador
do the eyes of ukrainian children
women and elderly killed by the russians
flesh before you
if they do
we may consider how to how to sponsor
a decision
to help you deal with
perpetration inducted traumatic stress
but now have some decency
and stop the egregious manipulation of
the security council
it is obscene
it would be too much dignifying
for the russian delegation if i end it
like here
like that
instead i would like
to quote a tweet
by dario
franceschini
the italian member of the government
who tweeted today
italy is really is ready
to rebuild the theater in mariupol
the cabinet of ministers has approved my
proposal to offer ukraine
the resources and means to rebuild it as
soon as possible
theaters
of all countries
belong to the whole humanity end of
quote
and i thank you
representative of ukraine
floor to the representative of poland mr
president distinguished members of
security council i would like to thank
uh
under secretary general
and the briefers for their important
interventions today
and i shall start by paying tribute to
the fearless ukrainian soldiers and
civilians alike
who defend their homeland freedom and
the u.n charter
they fight also for those who were
forced to flee
i should also express gratitude to the
work done by the u.n orchard unhsr
who and and its partners for maintaining
their
presence across ukraine and continuing
deliver to deliver the of the assistance
excellencies
the security council has gathered here
today to discuss the fastest growing
humanitarian and refugee crisis since
the second world war the consequence of
the russian aggression on ukraine
in light of this i would like to stress
the following points
firstly
this is 100 a war of choice
and the methods of waging it is also the
matter of choice
it is russia that decided to refer to
brutal force and discriminate weapons as
well as brutal siege tactics
now they go as far as targeting
journalists and kidnapping meyers of
ukrainian cities
in other words the aggressor decided to
change the nature of this conflict
it is a clear manifestation that the
russia deliberately
chose to create a humanitarian
catastrophe in ukraine and bluntly
disregards all the principles of
international communitarian law
and this should worry us all
actually disregarding the national law
has been a pattern that russia pursued
in syria and other places
to underpin this approach earlier today
the kremlin has rejected an order by the
national court of justice on the united
nations highest court to cease his
attack on ukraine
secondly
without resolving the dire humanitarian
situation there will be no peace
therefore we urge russia to change its
military modus operandi and allow full
and impeded crimentarian access and
relief to those in need
the safe passage of civilians from
different cities affected by the
conflict must be allowed
take the situation in mariopol where
still around
as 350.000 remain trapped in the cities
food water and medicines continue to dry
up
these people require urgent humanitarian
assistance and are exposed to safety and
security risks
therefore we call for immediate
ceasefire and humanitarian access to
most affected areas
thirdly
the humanitarian consequences of the
ongoing war are not limited to
ukrainians in their own territory
those who had fled remain affected too
already more than 3 million were forced
to leave ukraine as a result of russia's
military aggression
we have already reached the number of
over 1.9 million people who crossed our
border since february 24th
most of them found the shelter in poland
we have registered already 170
nationalities on our border
that means it considers us all and we
are all the victims of this aggression
excellencies
as a neighbor and close friend of
ukraine we see firsthand the dramatic
humanitarian consequences of this war
every day on the polish ukrainian border
we are witnessing growing number of
people who cross the border severely
traumatized
we believe that the involvement of u.n
bodies and agencies experience in
dealing with this kind of needs together
with the continued efforts of the polish
authorities will bring rapid and
appropriate solution
the spirit of solidarity poland will
continue to admit and provide shelter
food healthcare and safety to every
person in need regardless of their
nationality race or religious creed
aside from the
institutional care thousands of polish
people are organizing in a bottom-up way
showing the solidarity of ukraine
opening their homes to refugees and
volunteering and reception centers
excellencies as i'm delivering this
speech paulin's president's spouse a
cataclysm is building up international
coalition of first ladies and high-end
highnesses and all the people of
goodwill to effectively protect those in
vulnerable situations namely women
children elderly persons and persons
with disabilities many of them with
post-traumatic
disorder
the polish government has urgently
implemented new immigration measures for
ukrainian citizens fleeing their country
the new law that look took effect on
monday legalizes the state of citizens
of ukraine in order to enable them to
take up employment and provide them with
healthcare education and accommodation
in poland
it also offers temporary financial help
to polish citizens who welcome refugees
in their homes
ukrainian citizens may apply for
one-time subsidy to answer their basic
needs
the government will allocate funds for
schooling of ukrainian students
every ukrainian citizens fleeing the war
has been guaranteed access to the public
healthcare system in the same way as
police citizens have
we will continue to provide assistance
to ukrainian citizens fleeing the
horrors of war brought on them by russia
and i can tell you already we got the 45
thousands of pupils subscribed to police
schools from ukraine
but we and the other countries of the
region which i see the
ambassadors here in the room we all need
urgently an assistance of international
assistance in these good need
deeds
excellencies
today ukraine pays a high price for
defending its independence territorial
integrity and democracy and u.n charter
determination and courage of ukrainian
people inspires the world
we cannot fail them
it is crucial to show our solidarity of
ukraine and its people by acting now
and i think
adjourned
militarize ukraine to densify it and to
make ukraine a neutral state which which
is not threatening russia
negotiating negotiating are going on
what evidence are you going to bring
tomorrow on chemical and violence i have
additional information on that and i
think it deserves it new information
that it deserves being discussed in the
security council and that's not that's
not a joke that's not a russian
propaganda because more and more people
in the west including us and and uk are
asking questions on that uh military
buyer programs that that u.s was
in ukraine and not just in ukraine that
that applies to many uh
u.s sponsored laboratories around the
world
are you planning to use biological
weapons
is
hello
um
tomorrow
oh
yes
is
okay
that's what it is
his name is
all right
all right
who is putting fuel on fire except the
russian army
so you think
um
still
but it's funny
[Music]
any improvement on the end of this
horrible war
can you step
are you still paranoid with covet no
anyway tell me any improvement no there
is no improvement the
actions of the russian federation uh
continue to be very
brazen and
the atrocities are taking place
every day unfortunately
the president of the united states is
going to speak with the leader of china
because he's going to ask that china is
not going to help
no no the question is from what the
chinese ambassador said today what you
what you're what it is i look like a
chinese spokesperson i don't think you
if you're president going to speak to
the generals can i ask you uh after many
weeks of putting questions to me can you
identify yourself please
linebacker
okay
go ahead yes
when the time comes he may
all right have a good day goodbye